ايش هذا بشرطيه اردنيه اقنعت مواطنا بعدم
الانتحار ثم انهارت في البكاء انتشر
المقطع المصور على مواقع التواصل اجتماعي
لشرطيه سير اردنيه نجحت في اقناع شاب
بالعدول عن القاء نفسه من اعلى جسر في
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان وبدا على شرطيات
تاثر حين استطاعت انقاذ الشاب فجلس تبكي
الى جانب الطريق العام لتاثرها بما حصل
حبيبي الله يرضى عليك حبيبي
[موسيقى]
جدع جدع
تداول لرواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي صورا
لشاب عراقي وهو يجلس متحسرا على حافه
الرصيف يعمل في خدمه توصيل الطلبات فقد
تمت سرقه دراجته بعد دخول دخوله لاداء
الصلاه في احد المساجد بالعراق
[موسيقى]
نجحت سيده امريكيه في انقاذ طفلتها من
هجوم راكون مسعور فاجاها امام باب المنزل
ورصد الكاميرا مراقبه لقطات لهجوم الراكون
الذي غرس مخالبه في ساق الطفله وظل متعلقا
بها لحظه مغادره منزلها متوجهه الى
مدرستها وبين مكانه الطفله تكافح لتحرير
ساقها من الحيوان من دون جدوى ظهرت الام
التي سمعت صراخ ابنتها وركبت لمساعدتها
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم